hello guys my name is a channel and
welcome to yet another update video I'm
sorry I know there's been so many update
videos and I really hate myself for this
but I know you guys just want to see
content and you will get that this
update video is simply here to clear up
any confusion because I know if I
completely change the direction of my
channel I'll get a million comments
being like what's going on and this is
why the videos here so anyway now that
kind of disclaimer is out of the way
let's talk about the future of this
channel okay so first of all you guys
want to notice there aren't too many
videos okay that's yeah I know about
that don't worry I do make them so I do
know there aren't any the reason for
that is because I do have a full-time
job so because of that I really don't
have time at all basically to make
videos so here's how this thing is going
to work so first of all I've got a
full-time job as a software engineer at
EA games at a studio called fire monkeys
in melbourne australia so they're
responsible for games such as like real
racing and basically mobile games so
real racing the sims freeplay need for
speed so I've been mainly working on
need for speed and some other kind of
projects that i'm probably not allowed
to talk about but um anyway the point is
you know when you're getting home at
about six dollar probably about seven pm
and you have to cook yourself dinner by
the time you eat that dinner it's about
989 and you're pretty much exhausted n
you go to bed so weekdays are basically
busy and then there's a weekend where it
basically is my time off so the point is
there is not too much time but I do
still want to make videos because I
enjoy it ok so here is how this is going
to work currently I have two series
running in parallel ok I think I've
forgotten but I've run pretty sure I'm
right so there's games programming in
this flappy bird let's make flappy bird
right so this is what is going to happen
let's make flappy bird is the big the
big problem basically because it takes
too much time it takes me around six to
six to eight hours to pop out an episode
I know there are only like four minutes
to five
each but that is I'm serious I'm not
lying to you guys it takes me six to
eight hours because I need to write a
script I need to record very specific
video right I need to all I need to plan
out the code obviously for that first as
well but then script then the video then
I have to record audio based on that
script then I have to edit the video
together and that involves you know
programs like after effects working
together with premiere pro because there
are all these graphics and the screen
and animations to do anyway takes a lot
of time ok that's how long it takes and
I have to render it and uploaded so I
basically am NOT going to have time to
do that's my club about this year but I
don't want to leave you guys completely
kind of um kind of without an end
because I really hate starting things
and not finishing them ok games
programming is different because that
thing is basically never going to end
and I shouldn't does it again game
programming not anyway that thing's kind
of never going to end right but flappy
bird should end ok so here is what I
propose and you guys are going to either
agree or disagree but I'm pretty sure
you're going to agree because it's
really in the only solution I will
finish let's make flappy bird eventually
but until then I'm going to record
probably about one to two hours of just
me finishing the game from start to
finish so it's going to be because
really I haven't typed too much code I
might copy and paste segments here huh I
don't know because I'm just thinking
that mouth code i did will actually take
a while to type out again but you know
what doesn't matter I'll do it from
start to finish I think I'm pretty
confident it'll take me no more than two
and a half hours probably because I know
the code that I'm going on right I'm
just gonna literally right in front of
you guys I'm going to minimally explain
it I will do an overview of it so in
other words I won't be typing without
saying anything i will be talking about
what i'm typing but it'll be kind of
like a 3d game programming style of
video whereas just start to finish and
it's a really long video ok so that way
if you guys actually want to make flappy
bird a noob you don't want to see it at
the current stage and having to wait two
years and to finish it you will be able
to literally copy down my code and learn
and and get that game finished so I
think that'll satisfy you guys and the
thing is that'll take me exactly like
two and a half to three house or
whatever to actually do not which is
less than one episode ok so that's what
I'm proposing just to start to finish
less mobile army bird let's just get
that out of the way that series is
basically done okay in the sense that if
you really want to finish it you can
okay it so amazing depth obviously but
that's the way it's good that's the way
the cookie crumbles okay secondly as far
as game programming goes i'll do i'll do
that on my off time so anytime I kind of
feel like pushing out an episode or I
don't have you know I have a little bit
of extra time probably on weekends I'm
going to release an episode of game
programming now one video per week is
not enough content okay i don't i don't
want that to be my plan because it's
just not enough content i want to
interact with you guys a bit more i want
to push out more videos it's fun for me
to do so and i really don't want to I
really don't want to leave you guys with
anything because it's yeah because I
know you guys don't want that so here's
what i want to do i'm going to give you
kind of daily content this is how it's
going to work a lot um dare is coming
out pretty soon and by producing I mean
in April which is probably about 80 days
or so away i don't know i'm just
guessing but it's a bit less than three
months away wait what am I talking about
it's februari it's like two months away
anyway it's like two and a half months
away something like that but um I want
to make an engine Fallout and a I've
been trying to do this for ages but I'm
actually serious this time so what i
will do is basically a live stream
myself developing this game engine for a
lot of debt i'm going to do this almost
every night hopefully for about an hour
per night maybe maybe an hour and a half
to fine feeling particularly adventurous
here's the other thing though when i
come back from work and I've been
programming for like eight hours the
last thing I kind of want to do with do
more programming but I think this will
be more fun because it'll be a relaxed
kind of session and the programming I'm
doing isn't you know as performance
critical and as controlled let's just
say it's not as serious obviously is if
I'm making it you know if I'm coding
serious go to work but um the point is
yeah so it should I think that's a good
idea but what I will be doing is I will
be locally recording the episode so that
I can then upload them to YouTube okay
so I'm not gonna play any copyrighted
music during the streams unfortunately
or any music property for that matter
but I will treat them as almost as
videos so they'll be like our long
videos almost every day probably i'm
going to say i'm going to play it safe
and say every two days our long videos
that will be uploaded to this channel of
me just developing this engine and
talking about it and giving you guys
tips and tricks and one on and actually
just making something ok and that'll be
controlled that'll be probably on github
as well if you guys have any names for
this engine please let me know I don't
want to call Jenna that's pretty I want
to call it something cool not the chair
I wasn't the coolest time ever but you
know so that's kind of the idea ok I
really want to make that a series kind
of but the brilliant thing about that is
that I can just sit down talk for an
hour and livestream at the same time
game time in case you guys want to catch
it live and then it'll probably be
uploaded the next day to youtube or
something like that and I'm and like I'm
done so that makes me happy because I
really like making content and I I like
programming stuff in my spare time and
whatnot and that makes you guys happy
because that's a lot of content per day
um and it's just so easy for me to make
I just sit down it's like doing a live
commentary for like a video game or
something you just sit down you do what
you're done ok so that's the plan I hope
you guys agree with that and as far as
3d game programming goes I'm gonna treat
that in Cana the same way eventually
I've already talked about this i will
probably when I have a bit of spare time
which I don't know when that will happen
but when I do I'm going to redo that
whole series and it'll be more of a kind
of casual kind of maybe even almost like
a stream like fashion but it's not going
to be me answering comments every five
seconds or anything the streams are
going to be a bit different they're
gonna be pretty professional and then
maybe comments at the end or something
like that but that's the idea ok and
laden for that let them down engine I'm
thinking I might use lwjgl 3 which is
the new one so we'll see what we think
about that it'll probably be written in
java at this point just because um yeah
just surplus plus he's probably not the
best idea in London dare and I've talked
about that before but even though I much
prefer C++ over
java forum for basically for most things
unless I'm short on time so anyway
that's the idea okay please leave your
head feedback below you guys make this
channel obviously or 36,000 of you
thanks for helping me reach that number
but number by the way but that's the
idea so let me know what you think and
hopefully these streams will start
sometime next week and I actually first
I want to finish lappy but maybe even
tomorrow so we'll see what you guys say
okay so um yeah thanks for watching and
if you guys enjoy this video please hit
all hit the like button definitely leave
a comment letting me know what you think
and I'll see you guys very very soon
goodbye